bonjour les petits-enfants nous
attendons il était trop source
oui ils reviennent ce soir d'un long
voyage aussi plus avons bien ranger la
maison émis chaque chose à sa place
[Musique]
elle m'a tellement non pourquoi
bonjour juste ma cravate j'espère qu'ils
me les ont pâti du mouza regarde qui lui
j'ai acheté des gars de septembre ou au
litre à grands pas qu'est ce qui est
vraiment un gros joueur oui on le voit
là
[Musique]
mais oui les enfants
nous revoilà je vous avais promis que
nous reviendrions bientôt et vous le
voyez nous sommes revenues aller allegro
source descend petit louis mirabel sont
sûrement un patient de te revoir va vite
leur dire bonsoir à tout de suite pas
trop je descends de square a tout de
suite vos enfants je suis content de
vous voir qu'est-ce que c'est un collier
avec des fleurs ou et avec des fleurs
[Musique]
où
benoît utilise ou la loi on est même
allé jusqu'à le tata tahiti ouais
parfaitement et il ya ce que tu nous a
rapporté regarder de belles fleurs des
banques en silence c'est l'époque et je
vous montrerai toutes les photos que
nous avons fait pendant notre moyen
maintenant que vous voyez ulysse matin
oddo
bien évidement vous êtes soyez
tranquilles à leurs noms mais huit
pendant la nuit
envoyez votre chance aux amateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit tous mes petits amis
nous sommes très content d'être venu
vous voir car vous savez vous nous avez
beaucoup manqué mais nous avons été très
heureux de recevoir toutes les belles
lettres que vous nous avez écrites elles
nous ont fait très plaisir
alors en route nos ados mais les enfants
bonne nuit dormait vite
à deux pas
[Musique]
oh